hi everyone brad here from quarantine
Brad Pitt ladies and gents the king of
surprise cameos it's really exciting
the Oscar winner filmed a special video
message for the graduating class of
Missouri State University which is
located in his hometown of Springfield
Missouri yes it is Brad yes it is
Brad shoutout was shared on Twitter by
university president Clif smart and the
school's mascot boomer the bear hi
everyone
Brad here from quarantine with a shout
out to the graduating class Missouri
State University must be very strange
doing this in these trying times but no
we're rooting for you moment to pause
and swoon Brad just said he's rooting
for you and continue our money's on you
to make this world a better place and we
wish you all the best in your future
endeavors
so you did it you made it enjoy Congrats
again and think big you're crying
anyway Brad's been keeping himself
pretty busy in quarantine in April he
appeared on John Krasinski's some good
news webseries delivering the weather
sort of Brad how's it looking out there
looks uh pretty good
yeah thanks Brad and then there was this
good evening I'm dr. Anthony foul
that's Brad doing his best impersonation
of dr. Anthony Fauci on Saturday Night
Live they have the tests and the tests
are beautiful I don't know if I would
describe the tests as beautiful unless
your idea of beauty is having a cotton
swab tickle your brain and he gave us
those full-body chills when he set the
humor aside for a hot SEC to think
doctor pouchy and all the essential
workers to the real doctor foutch you
thank you for your calm and your clarity
in this unnerving time thank you to the
medical workers first responders and
their families for being on the front
line and now lives kinda from all across
America it's Saturday night
[Music]